Public Sénat en partenariat avec
l'équipe vous présente sport etc
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous ravie de vous retrouver
pour une nouvelle saison de sport etc
dans 10 mois la France accueille les
Jeux olympiques mais nous sommes déjà au
centre du jeu sportif avec la Coupe du
monde de rugby plus que jamais le sport
est au cœur de notre quotidien je vous
donne donc rendez-vous deux fois par
mois cette saison pour sport etc tout de
suite le sommaire de ce premier numéro
une seule médaille au championnats du
monde d'athlétisme doit-on s'inquiéter à
moins d'un an des Jeux olympiques de
Paris 204
l'Arabie Saoudite investit sans compter
dans le football mais aussi le golfe ou
l'équitation simple passade ou nouvelle
acteur solide quels sont les objectifs
des Saoudiens
les fans de rugby ont envahi la France
depuis le début de la Coupe du Monde
ambiance festive bon résultat sportif le
Mondial de rugby est-il déjà un succès
enfin la France se rêve en science
sportive mais que restera-t-il de nos Jo
quelle place aura le sport à préparer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et pour débattre aujourd'hui j'ai
l'immense plaisir d'accueillir Marie
Barsac vous êtes directrice de l'impact
et d'héritage de Paris 2024 bonjour
Jean-Philippe Leclerc directeur adjoint
de la rédaction de l'équipe notre
partenaire pour cette émission Florian
Gazan vous êtes éditorialiste et
Philippe pangero ancien rugbyman
professionnel chargé de mission
stratégiques pour la Fédération
française de rugby auprès de la Ligue
nationale vous êtes également l'auteur
du livre au cœur de l'ovélie aux
éditions Le Robert on jettera un petit
coup d'oeil dessus dans quelques
instants justement avant de nous plonger
dans l'été sportif un petit mot sur ce
début de Coupe du Monde bon
l'enthousiasme est au rendez-vous c'est
un peu cette bonne augure quand même
pour la suite Marie oui c'est sûr quand
en plus l'équipe de France gagne on sait
que tout le peuple français est derrière
on attend que ça nous aussi pour les
Jeux Olympiques et Paris du même 4 que
nos athlètes performent
Philippe vous êtes heureux de ce début
de compétition vous êtes heureux de
l'enthousiasme très très c'est une très
bonne publicité pour notre sport on a
tout ce qu'il faut pour se servir de ça
comme d'une rame de lancement pour
retrouver des licenciés on a des têtes
d'affiche sportive on a une équipe qui
gagne j'avais très peur de ce match
d'ouverture qui était dans toutes les
têtes depuis très longtemps j'attendais
de voir comment les joueurs allaient
être capables de le digérer on les a vu
un peu empruntés en première période
mais quand tout ça s'est déclenché on a
senti que la compétition était vraiment
lancée
vous avez aimé la cérémonie d'ouverture
Florian
ouais je sais qu'il y a eu des petites
polémiques là dessus par rapport à une
certaine idée de la France moi je trouve
ça plutôt bon enfant dans ce style un
peu Amélie Poulain oui c'est un peu
cliché mais d'un autre côté bon on n'est
pas là non plus pour faire des choses
trop c'est l'image de la France les
étrangers viennent aussi en France pour
ce côté là un petit peu un petit peu
Émilie donc là ils en ont eu ils ont mis
une Parisienne
non ça va ça allait non c'était c'était
un beau début de compétition une belle
une belle ouverture et ça lance ce qu'on
attend être une très belle coupe du
monde
c'est normal
c'est très bien parti d'un point de vue
sportif après au niveau de
l'organisation il y a quand même
quelques quoi
on y reviendra avant moi je veux rester
sur les choses positives je j'emprunte
Philippe quelques mots de votre livre
vous avez d'ailleurs emprunté des mots à
Jean-Pierre Rives qui est un ancien
international le rugby c'est l'histoire
d'un ballon avec des copains autour
quand le ballon n'est plus là il reste
les copains parce que c'est pas
exactement ce qu'on est en train de
vivre pour l'instant
pour jouer au rugby et pour faire du
sport mais c'est redevenu la maxime de
Fabien galtiere c'était la déposer sur
son truc il voulait plus l'avoir mais là
pour prier d'accord très bien on va
revenir sur cette coupe du monde dans
quelques instants mais avant cela petit
retour en arrière regarde dans le
rétroviseur de cet été sportif
une seule médaille au championnat du
monde d'athlétisme le basket masculin
éliminé en face de poule au mondiaux le
sport français sera-t-il au rendez-vous
des Jeux Olympiques c'est le hors piste
de sport etc
[Musique]
Jean-Philippe juste avant le début de
l'automne est-ce que l'été français vous
a inquiété pour l'avenir donc des sports
ont été plus inquiétants que d'autres on
a été plutôt rassurés par la natation
française même si elle est un peu Léon
marchand dépendante c'est ce que
j'allais dire là vous partez sur la
natation c'est quand même deux
Superstars qu'on a c'est tout non
en revanche c'est sûr qu'il y a eu des
grosses grosses alertes il y en a eu
deux énormes avec le basket puisque les
Français ont été éliminés dès le premier
tour des mondiaux et puis
l'athlétisme avec seulement une médaille
une médaille d'argent sur le 4x4 après
pour moi c'est vraiment deux situations
complètement différentes parce que les
Français étaient favoris en basket donc
ils sont tombés très haut en revanche
l'athlétisme malheureusement ça n'a pas
été une énorme surprise on sait très
bien qu'on a de trois athlètes grand
maximum qui peuvent qui peuvent
performer notre meilleure chance de
médailles Kevin Meyer c'est blessé en
début de en début de compétition donc à
partir de là
comprendre qu'il faut se préserver on
est à un an des Jeux pour un athlète se
blesser gravement certains athlètes se
sont pas déplacés aux Championnats du
Monde justement pour ça on peut espérer
mieux basket en tout cas ils feront pas
pire facilement en revanche l'athlétisme
c'est pas l'été qu'on pouvait attendre
par exemple si on prend les Anglais un
an avant Londres il y avait avant les
Jeux de Londres il y avait vraiment une
montée en puissance en particulier
en cyclisme sur piste et même en
athlétisme là la montée en puissance on
la voit on la voit pas trop donc est-ce
qu'il y a un effet Giro JO à rebours ou
les français se sentent déjà écrasés par
l'enjeu enfin après il y a quand même
des exemples positifs donc on a parlé au
marchand là les Français en rugby ils
avaient une pression quand même
incroyable un match d'ouverture contre
les contre les All Blacks et ils s'en
sont sortis ils avaient aussi des
blessés enfin dans la grande boîte aux
excuses ils en avaient quand même
quelques-unes et ils ont pu en sortir
plein et puis finalement ils ont voilà
ils ont performé comme des grands
heureusement que le rugby nous sort de
cet été pas vraiment génial Philippe
c'est ça qui va nous redonner j'espère
en tout cas que ça va insuffler quelque
chose qui va perdurer jusqu'au jusqu'au
jeu alors on n'a pas trop aimé nous dans
la communauté préféré rugby entendre
qu'on était une répétition des jeux
[Rires]
mais je pense pas que ce soit
soit en perdus
en termes d'engouement puis on voit
peut-être qu'on est en hauteur mais que
politiquement quand même Emmanuel Macron
a beaucoup beaucoup surfé dessus et je
pense que le storytelling a démarré avec
le rugby pour se terminer à après les
Jeux
j'ose espérer que ça va amener une
nouvelle vision politique du rôle du
sport dans notre pays parce qu'on voit
on voit quand même est-ce que les
résultats de de cet été c'est pas
quelque part une une défaillance de la
politique de ces dernières années c'est
trop tard Florian pour les jeux c'est
une vaste question moi j'ai quand même
toujours tendance à croire que les JO
c'est quand même un moment un peu
particulier et que les résultats non
avant veulent pas forcément dire grand
chose j'avais quand même il y a cette
notion de rendez-vous d'être là au
rendez-vous et de dossier aussi de bien
attaquer les jeux souvent on voit que
quand dans les premiers jours on
commence à faire des médailles et un
effet d'entraînement absolument donc non
je pense qu'il faut être il faut être
positif il y a aussi beaucoup de choses
qui marchent dans le sport français nous
voler marche très fort nous footballeurs
avec Thierry Henry on peut de faire
quelque chose on a quand même pas mal il
joue pas il est il est entraîneur non je
préfère le préciser
de l'équipe de France
on a quand même beaucoup de disciplines
y compris dans les nouvelles on peut
performer donc je pense c'est très
français d'être un peu pessimiste et
défaitiste avant donc je préfère qu'on
soit mauvais un an avant et bon pendant
que bon un an avant et mauvais au jour J
voilà à choisir c'est le succès des jeux
il dépendra de nos athlètes ou oui
forcément un peu l'engouement populaire
en tout cas c'est sûr on a vu en
Angleterre que tout avait décollé quand
les médailles sont arrivés c'est de la
même chose à Tokyo ou quelques semaines
avant les Jeux à Tokyo il y a eu
beaucoup de pessimisme et dès que les
médailles sont arrivés le pays tout
entier a soutenu son équipe nationale en
tout cas nous cette année on va beaucoup
travailler pour faire connaître tous les
équipes les athlètes de l'équipe de
France olympique et paralympique pour
nous c'est extrêmement important que
tous les Français soient derrière les
bleus et les connaissent donc on a
programme dans les écoles notamment
qu'on a déjà entamé mais qui vont se
poursuivre plus plus pour que bien tous
les Français sachent encourager les
athlètes et connaissent les sports
olympiques parce que tout le monde ne
connaît pas tous les sports et je sais
que ça vous tient beaucoup à coeur les
équipements le évidemment on en parlera
plus longuement de l'héritage est-ce que
on n'est pas arrivé trop tard est-ce
qu'on a manqué d'équipement à un moment
Jean-Philippe Leclerc Marie
je pense que sur le haut niveau il y a
une révolution avec la création de
l'Agence Nationale pour le sport un peu
tard et j'ai peur qu'elle soit arrivée
un peu tard et que par exemple on parle
de l'athlétisme mais on voit bien que la
courbe de l'athlétisme au niveau des
médailles si on part de 2016 des jeux de
de Rio où on a eu je crois 6 médailles
on est redescendu un peu sur Londres
2017 et puis alors depuis c'est la
catastrophe et je pense que
effectivement le clodonesta et ses
équipes ont eu l'ADMA d'ailleurs
eux-mêmes ils ont eu un petit temps de
retard et on commence à entendre une
petite musique de dire oui bon alors
Paris ce sera peut-être pas terrible
ça sera génial et Brisbane alors là on
sera vraiment au top du top oh c'est un
peu dommage quand même il faut être bien
à Paris ça serait ce serait pas plus mal
quoi mais justement ça vient de ça vient
de l'école le sport il faut être prêt
depuis longtemps le président de la
République a rappelé il y a quelques
jours la politique mise en place
d'activités à l'école je sais que c'est
très important pour vos maris on va
écouter le président de la République on
met en place
maintenant la meilleure de sport en
primaire qui est une petite révolution
mais qui fait que vous allez avoir des
collégiens qui arrivent qui ont
normalement une autre pratique ce qu'on
va aussi développer c'est le sport étude
un des fléaux qu'on a pas administratif
du ça mais c'est l'obésité gagne du
terrain chez nos ados nos jeunes etc et
donc le sport va permettre de mieux
lutter contre ça et plus généralement ça
donne de la confiance c'est aussi très
important c'est que ça apprend les
règles une certaine discipline le
respect de l'adversaire la vie en commun
alors j'ai lu dans une tribune au Monde
une tribune de Maxime travers et Jean
griffé de professeur universitaires qui
rappelait que bouger ce n'est pas du
sport alors faire du sport à l'école
c'est capital mais est-ce qu'on a pas
perdu notre âme de compétiteur
de compétiteur se dépassait gagner
vouloir est-ce qu'on l'a déjà eu parce
qu'on est très imprégné
de la phrase de Coubertin quand même
l'important c'est de participer on a
quand même entendu souvent et je crois
que c'est important pour nos jeunes de
dédramatiser la compétition et de
trouver le plaisir dans le sport au-delà
de la victoire parce qu'on peut
s'épanouir sans gagner mais je crois
qu'à un moment il faut basculer
sans gagner mais il faut gagner un
moment oui mais il faut déjà être en
capacité d'aller prendre du plaisir à
faire du sport en club c'est vrai les 30
minutes d'activité physique quotidiennes
à l'école sont faites pour que tous les
Français tous les enfants sachent
maîtriser les habilités motrices qui
font que ils prendront plaisir à faire
du sport en club si vous ne savez pas
sauter lancer bouger en fait danser être
habile avec votre corps et bien vous
n'allez pas prendre de plaisir à faire
du rugby du basket du hand ou de la
gymnastique donc c'est ça aussi qui est
important c'est à dire d'avoir un socle
minimum de maîtrise de ses habilités
donc ça c'est ce qui se Acquier à
l'école primaire donc les 30 minutes
d'activités physiques quotidiennes elles
sont évidemment complémentaires à l'EPS
ça c'est très important à dire ici elles
existent c'est parce que aujourd'hui la
situation est grave le niveau d'activité
physique de nos enfants et nettement en
deçà des recommandations de l'OMS et je
rappelle juste EPS et activités
éducation physique et sportive c'est les
cours on a tous eu le sport
il faut les deux en fait il faut être en
bonne forme physique et donc ça c'est
les 30 minutes d'activité physique
quotidienne et puis il faut évidemment
faire de l'EPS pour découvrir la des
disciplines sportives et puis aussi
maîtriser l'éducation l'EPS c'est aussi
une matière
pédagogique importante dans le parcours
des enfants oui c'est ce que rappelait
le président de la République donc ça
c'est important effectivement pour les
jeunes et en vue de jeux olympiques ou
de grandes compétitions internationales
ce qu'il faut également c'est cet esprit
de compétition je donne on parlait de
Léon marchand il est par il ça exilé il
s'entraîne aujourd'hui avec l'ancien
entraîneur de de Phelps Bob Bowman aux
États-Unis
c'est parce que justement on n'a pas
cette je suis désolée d'utiliser ce
terme mais cette mentalité de tueur dans
le sport qu'on est obligé d'aller la
découvrir enfin d'aller l'acquérir aux
États-Unis on avait l'habitude de dire
que en fait les Anglo-Saxons inventaient
les sports et que nous on a inventait
les compétitions et que c'était les
Allemands les Américains et les
Soviétiques à l'époque tout le temps les
Russes qui les gagnaient à la fin c'est
un peu changé mais après par exemple là
on parle de modèle français ou en fait
le sport était pas du tout le bienvenu à
l'école si ce n'est avec quelques heures
comme ça la moitié de l'école la moitié
de la classe se faisait dispenser alors
que le monde est anglo-saxon le sport il
a toujours été au centre du modèle
éducatif et non seulement en Angleterre
non seulement aux Etats-Unis mais aussi
par exemple quand on parle de la
Jamaïque et du de l'athlétisme c'est
impossible quand on a un bon athlète un
bon sprinter en Jamaïque il est repéré
tout de suite dès l'école à l'école il a
7-8 ans il peut pas échapper à il peut
pas échapper aux mailles du filet alors
que nous on n'a pas cette tradition là
on pas on l'a encore moins à
l'université alors là quand on voit les
universités anglaises les universités
Oxford contre Cambridge les universités
américaines ou le sport est vraiment au
cœur du financement au cœur de la
compétition c'est un ciment entre les
anciens le sport à l'université en
France c'est vraiment la 43e roue du
carrosse donc il y a tout un modèle à
changer là il y a une prise de
conscience par les autorités politiques
il y a au moins un discours ferme là
dessus il y a des mesures qui ont été
prises maintenant voilà on va ça on va
pas tout changer en un an pour arriver
oui c'est quand même c'est quand même un
peu tard après cette mentalité là on a
quand même des sportifs qui l'ont on a
eu toute une génération extraordinaire
qui nous a fait avant on était les les
rois de la de la loose magnifique les
perdants magnifiques
maintenant on a quand même Zinédine
Zidane de Saint-Étienne les poteaux
carrés Glasgow mais quand même après il
y a eu la génération Platini Ino Noah
pros donc on a basculé dans dans autre
chose les noms que vous venez de citer
les plus jeunes il faut leur rappeler
qui c'est
Zinédine Zidane et Kylian Mbappe ils
savent que ce sont des vainqueurs ce
sont effectivement des
personnages c'est souvent des des
Français qui sont allés s'expatrier pour
des raisons
le jeu de sport et c'est souvent en se
confrontant dans d'autres pays où cette
mentalité là par contre elle est là qui
se sont nourries de ça et pareil les
jeunes générations qui sont très
imprégnées de basket NBA sport américain
ou là vraiment c'est les stats gagner et
ça ça rejailli c'est vrai que la
mentalité française elle est en train
aussi développée par rapport à ça c'est
pas c'est pas ça de gagner en fait en
France
on est suspect en France la bonne place
c'est numéro 2 mais non aujourd'hui je
pense que les jeunes générations ont
envie d'être numéro un numéro 2 ça
intéresse plus quoi il y a certains
athlètes qui ont choisi l'exil pour
d'autres
raisons une vague d'exil effectivement
sans précédent et sans réel ambition
sportive à frapper les joueurs de
football cet été direction l'Arabie
Saoudite et son championnat
multimillionnaire doit-on craindre que
les championnats européens soient
durablement déstabilisés quel impact
géopolitique c'est la confrontation de
sport etc
[Musique]
alors des stars vieillissantes aux
jeunes prometteurs l'Arabie saoudite a
fait main basse sur une colonie de
footballeurs de talents Florian Gazan
vous allez regarder le championnat
saoudien ben oui je le regardais c'était
on peut le regarder c'est la preuve
quand même qu'ils ont déjà réussi leur
couple puisque maintenant
sur Canal
155 pays forcément il y a un effet de
curiosité parce que malgré tout c'est
des sportifs qui sont je peux pas dire
vieillissant parce que ce sera un peu
insultant
en pleine activité qui était encore des
grands clubs ne serait-ce que l'année
dernière oui on a envie de voir ça on a
envie de voir où est-ce que ça va nous
emmener en fait ou quand on va se
développer ce championnat parce qu'on a
un regard un petit peu toujours un petit
peu on les prend un petit peu de haut en
disant un peu condescendant un peu
en oubliant que finalement c'est pas les
premiers à avoir fait ça j'ai un même à
une époque quand l'Angleterre qui est un
pays de football a commencé à sortir des
millions et des millions pour attirer
les meilleurs joueurs de l'Europe
entière ça te dérangeait personne donc
l'Arabie Saoudite le fait pourquoi pas
alors après évidemment il y a toutes les
notions de droits de l'homme etc on
parle beaucoup d'argent mais on parle
moins de de banque éventuellement de
scrupules qu'on peut aller de se rendre
là-bas pour finalement aller dans le
sens de ce soft power quand elle fait le
Qatar voilà on a bien compris la
stratégie de l'Arabie Saoudite mais moi
je me dis oui j'ai envie de le voir
j'aime le football il y a des beaux
joueurs qui sont là-bas pourquoi je
regarderai pas en fait alors
Jean-Philippe on compare souvent
effectivement le
Qatar et l'Arabie Saoudite là on peut
imaginer cette arrivée de joueurs donc
on se dit ils vont ils veulent la Coupe
du monde comme le Qatar pourtant
l'Arabie Saoudite el Qatar c'est quand
même deux pays qui n'ont pas grand chose
à voir géographiquement
ennemi jusqu'à la dernière du monde où
il y a une forme de réconciliation très
fort grâce au sport après ils ont eu
deux approches complètement différentes
parce que le kata a eu des des joueurs
étrangers qui sont venus qui continuent
à venir récemment Marco verratti mais
mais pas avec pas avec cette échelle là
et c'est vrai que le football en Arabie
Saoudite est quand même plus il y a une
tradition beaucoup plus forte que que au
Qatar il y a un championnat depuis
beaucoup plus longtemps il y a des
équipes il y a 18 clubs dans le
championnat comme un niveau plus fort
puisque le enfin les Saoudiens quand
même battu les les la seule équipe à
battre les Argentins lors de la dernière
Coupe du monde donc c'était pas des
joueurs naturalisés donc ils ont eu deux
approches différentes là le l'Arabie
saoudite a longtemps été un peu en
position de de d'observatrice ils ont
regardé un peu comment ça se passait ils
ont vu le quand même le succès
médiatique et diplomatique de de la
Coupe du Monde au Qatar et ils ont une
approche différente ils ont ils ont
investi aussi dans dans quelques clubs
en Europe principalement
à nettoyer il a son fameux plan vision
2030 qui concerne pas que le qui
concerne oui il a 37 ans il est jeune ça
ne concerne pas que le sport loin de là
ça concerne aussi la culture ça concerne
aussi le tourisme avec des
investissements touristiques absolument
démentiel donc il y a cette espèce de
paradoxe ou d'un côté on pour la société
il y a quand même eu quelques avancées
notamment sur la condition des femmes et
à côté de ça on peut encore avoir des
des actes des décisions complètement
barbares avec récemment une condition
une condamnation à mort d'un opposant
pour quelques tweets parce qu'il est le
frère d'un opposant en exil donc donc
voilà et on a nos footballeurs au milieu
ils sont dans une sorte d'enjeu de
diplomatique qui nous disent que ils ne
vont pas là-bas que pour l'argent et
qu'ils espèrent revenir en Europe après
enfin bon tu voulais donner l'exemple de
Jordan Anderson qui est un ancien joueur
de Liverpool qui était qui est une
figure de la de l'équipe nationale
anglaise et qui était surtout bien connu
pour son implication dans la défense des
homosexuels notamment au Royaume-Uni et
il a débarqué en Arabie Saoudite cet été
il a donné une explication quant à
présence en Arabie Saoudite je vous
laisse juge
tout le monde devrait respecter la
religion et la culture des autres avant
les femmes ne pouvaient pas jouer au
football ici c'est différent maintenant
donc les choses peuvent changer petit à
petit
aujourd'hui il faut toujours se
justifier quand on va jouer en Arabie
Saoudite il faut se justifier quand on
fait un choix pour l'argent qu'on n'a
pas envie d'assumer parce qu'on sait
très bien qu'ils sont tous partis là-bas
pour gagner beaucoup d'argent et il y a
pas de problème avec ça finalement une
carte de footballeur c'est très fragile
une blessure puis c'est terminé donc ils
ont envie d'engranger et on peut pas
leur en vouloir donc on se justifie
parce qu'encore une fois ça fait c'est
pas un dessin très très noble donc on
trouve des explications pour y aller
mais faut assumer c'est pas très très
grave et il y a un autre point de vue
celui de Cristiano Ronaldo qui a été
l'un des plus premier grands joueurs à
rejoindre le championnat d'Arabie
Saoudite lui il a une vision presque
romantique de son départ
Ronaldo le romantique lui il a le
sentiment qu'il va faire changer les
choses
pour moi c'est une grande opportunité
non seulement dans le football mais
aussi pour changer la mentalité de la
nouvelle génération personne ne le sait
mais je peux dire maintenant j'avais des
offres avec de nombreux clubs en Europe
mais aussi au Brésil en Australie aux
États-Unis et même au Portugal qui ont
tenté de me faire signer mais j'avais
donné ma parole à ce club pour
l'opportunité de développer non
seulement le football mais aussi l'autre
partie de cette incroyable pays
Philippe est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment que ça c'est obligatoire pour
tous les gens qui vont qui vont jouer
là-bas de faire cet exercice de dire
combien on veut faire changer les choses
surtout ne pas dire du mal de l'Arabie
Saoudite puisque ça fait partie de leur
contrat c'est quelque chose qui vous
dérange en tant qu'en sciences sportif
non ça me dérange pas ce qui est
dérangeant c'est un peu l'hypocrisie et
la schizophrénie autour de tout ça c'est
à dire que d'un côté il y a cette
volonté de gagner beaucoup d'argent mais
de pas l'assumer pour faire la promotion
d'un pays qui met des milliards pour
s'ouvrir au monde mais qui évolue quand
même de façon très très modérée dans son
ouverture au monde donc ça me perturbe
parce que je trouve pas ça très cohérent
mais le choix de l'argent il se comprend
faudrait qu'il soit un peu plus assumé
ce qui serait intéressant c'est de voir
dans quelques mois comment ça va se
passer et comment la vie de ces gens-là
dans ce pays-là va se passer parce que
là tout ça c'est très nouveau moi la
seule chose qui me perturbe beaucoup
c'est que c'est ce manque de
communication de ces pays-là le Qatar
comme l'Arabie Saoudite il y aurait un
storytelling à faire alors moi par
exemple je savais pas que il y avait une
vraie culture du foot en Arabie Saoudite
ce serait bien de l'expliquer ça ça
crédibiliserait un peu plus la stratégie
mais du jour au lendemain c'est pour ça
qu'il existe fort etc merci beaucoup
le prochain objectif c'est quoi les Jeux
Olympiques la Coupe du monde de football
asiatiques ce qui peut sembler bizarre
mais en fait c'est là aussi c'est très
différent du Qatar c'est un très grand
pays l'Arabie Saoudite avec des paysages
complètement différents donc ils ont un
massif montagneux bon c'est pas les
Alpes et encore moins les vrais mais ils
ont quand même donc ils vont organiser
les Jeux d'hiver asiatiques garantit en
train de carbone zéro évidemment
mais ils ont une ambition immense oui et
le sentiment d'avoir des des d'avoir des
étapes à rattraper le sentiment je pense
d'avoir été un peu derrière le petit
Qatar alors que eux c'est la très grande
Arabie Saoudite donc
autoriser cette après ils font pas
n'importe quoi parce qu'on a toujours
l'impression que voilà il lâche de
l'argent dans tous les sens alors il
lâche des gros salaires parce
qu'évidemment mais par contre sur le sur
la globalité des transferts ils ont
dépensé je crois cet été justement 900
millions d'euros et c'est à peu près
moins que la première que la première
ligue la première ligue c'est 2
milliards et la Ligue 1 même on est au
même niveau donc voilà donc c'est pas
non plus voilà il faut aussi un peu
casser cet image
qui interpellent qui dit que ça dans
quel club en fait c'est 4 clubs c'est
quatre clubs qui ont dépensé on voit les
chiffres 817 millions d'euros 803 pour
pour la Ligue 1 de 300 ou 350 rien que
pour le Paris Saint-Germain en Ligue 1
je le précise quand même mais
oui non non
d'accord oui ça marche et ça ça a marché
mais c'est vrai quand on imagine les
dépenses de l'Arabie Saoudite
j'aurais pu imaginer qu'ils avaient
dépensé plus que la première ligue
d'ailleurs la première ligue c'est le
championnat qui râle le plus contre
l'Arabie Saoudite en disant ils sont en
train de doute tout déstabiliser enfin
c'est quand même les Anglais oui bon
après les Anglais ils sont très sont
très serrés c'est pas une île pour rien
et ils ont surtout ils vont surtout
effectivement cette concurrence
dangereuse parce que mine de rien quand
même l'Arabie Saoudite des peuples un
peu les compétitions et voilà et ça ça
va forcément affaiblir leur championnat
la Ligue des Champions il y a des
joueurs qui seront plus là il faut quand
même aussi on peut se poser cette
question là après l'Arabie Saoudite
force pas les gens à venir mais c'est
vrai que soit longueur on se dit
finalement peut-être que un jour
championnat d'Arabie Saoudite sera plus
sympa à regarder que la Ligue 1
parce que le modèle économique du foot
repose tellement sur les droits télé que
si les grosses têtes d'affic européenne
rejoignent le championnat ça va
forcément appauvrir les négos et donc
parler dans les prochaines semaines sur
sport etc avec l'appel d'offres
concernant la Ligue 1 le championnat de
France de football on en reparlera ce
sera au mois d'octobre
vous n'étiez pas au courant peut-être
Philippe mais il y a un championnat
féminin de football en Arabie Saoudite
il existe depuis 2 ans Florian vous me
regardez un petit peu difficile
si elles peuvent y aller en voiture et
elles peuvent même donc jouer il y a une
équipe nationale l'équipe nationale
n'était pas à la Coupe du monde en
Australie et en Nouvelle-Zélande c'est
la Coupe du Monde qui a eu lieu cet été
elle n'était pas qualifiée mais
toutefois elles avaient elles avaient la
possibilité de participer c'est une
nouveauté effectivement l'équipe a été
créée en février 2022 Coupe du Monde
Féminine justement
31,6 millions de téléspectateurs en
France malgré des horaires défavorables
puisque ça se déroulait en Australie en
Nouvelle-Zélande la Coupe du Monde
féminine a été un immense succès un
immense succès d'audience et un immense
succès sportif
c'est juste
pour les Français c'est mitigé mais le
niveau sportif de cette Coupe du Monde
est enfin c'est du jamais vu dans
l'histoire c'est à dire que on a eu le
sentiment d'un d'une élite plus compact
c'est à dire que il y avait les pays
traditionnels qu'on connaît depuis
longtemps type Angleterre États-Unis
Norvège etc et puis on a vu des ce qu'on
a on pensait être des petits pays et qui
en fait était pas si petit que ça type
Jamaïque Philippines donc ça c'est
plutôt rassurant c'est à dire que on
arrive il y a des nations qui
progressent donc ça c'est plutôt bien et
c'est vrai que le niveau était plutôt le
niveau de jeu était plutôt pas mal après
en France il y a quand même eu un
problème de de d'audience TV parce que
parce que c'était en plein milieu des
très honnêtement
après après c'était un pari enfin
c'était un choix de la FIFA plutôt il
faut souvenir que la FIFA un moment
était très critique envers les
diffuseurs en disant comment ça se fait
que vous nous achetez pas notre
compétition le même etc mais c'est eux
qui ont fait choix là et pourquoi ils
ont fait ce choix de date bizarre c'est
qu'en fait il voulait laisser la place
alors compétition de Coupe du monde des
clubs n'ont pas pour les femmes et mais
pour les hommes donc ils ont fait un
choix bizarre ils auraient voulu que le
monde entier l'assume pour pour donc le
président de la Fédération
Internationale international de football
a dit aux femmes qu'il fallait qu'elle
montre que elle valait la peine d'être
regardée je le voulais absolument et
vous venez de le répéter donc Marie
Marsac vous l'avez regardé cette Coupe
du Monde vous allez regarder les bleus
j'ai regardé où il est l'image des Bleus
enfin quelques-uns des mages des Bleus
évidemment je viens du football j'ai
travaillé 8 ans à la Fédération de
football donc j'ai vraiment un
attachement particulier au foot et
notamment féminin qui a vraiment bien
progressé dans notre pays ce qu'on a
quand même vu que cette coupe du monde
c'est que les pays je pense à l'Espagne
l'Angleterre comme massivement investi
quand même sur le foot féminin c'est
Paris gagnant et peut-être que nous on
doit faire encore plus fort encore plus
à investir sur le niveau de nos
compétitions féminines investir c'est
les clubs les stades les qualités de la
retransmission enfin il y a tout un
travail en France je pense à mener on
n'est pas loin mais il y a encore du
boulot c'est quand même deux salles deux
ambiances parce qu'effectivement cette
coupe du monde doit être plutôt été un
succès en audience et même ça a été
assez surprenant on sait pas forcément
qu'à votre tels audience en télévision
mais quand je vois que la finale du
Trophée des championnes première édition
c'est jouer à trois devant 5000
personnes Paris contre Lyon c'est quand
même les deux grandes équipes françaises
voire européennes je me dis comme qui
est un peu de boulot et ça me fait un
peu penser à la précédente Coupe du
monde c'était déroulé en France on
s'était dit ça y est c'était le départ
c'était le départ
s'est retombé comme un soufflé donc
ouais il y a quand même encore un peu de
travail il faut pas se cacher derrière
la Coupe du Monde quoi parce que la
capitaine des Bleus Wendy renard la
rappeler on a pris du retard en France
elle l'a dit absolument
considéré et pratiquement comme un des
clubs les plus courants tout sport
à qui on a volé la victoire en fait le
baiser forcé de Luis roubialès le
président de la Fédération espagnole de
football en mondovision qui a forcé
Jenny hermoso à l'embrasser enfin
c'était un geste absolument terrible
est-ce qu'on va vers un meetou du sport
en tout cas en Espagne il a eu lieu je
rappelle que robiales a été forcé à la
démission il a mis deux semaines quand
même pour démissionner
c'est un petit peu long on a quand même
sorti qu'il y avait encore quelques
freins en Espagne il y a comme du
travail parce que
la Fédération la soutenu pendant assez
longtemps ces petits camarades donc
voilà ça a mis du temps il va falloir
que ça suive son chemin après on n'est
pas les meilleurs placés en France pour
donner des leçons par rapport à ça on se
souvient ce qui s'est passé à la
Fédération voilà donc oui il faut que
les mentalités évoluent il faut que ça
aille vite ça n'a que trop traîné
cette affaire est le plus triste
effectivement c'est que les pauvres
espagnols leur victoire a complètement
été volée par ce baiser quoi et qu'on a
déjà oublié qu'elles ont été champion du
monde pour la première fois de leur
histoire et c'est ça le plus dramatique
mais elles ont été formidables on va
parler rugby à présent la Coupe du Monde
a débuté le 8 septembre dernier les
supporters du monde entier sont au
rendez-vous ils sont partout autour de
nous dans les rues les stades sont
pleins est-ce déjà un succès est-ce de
bonne augure pour les Jeux Olympiques
c'est l'affiche de sport etc
[Musique]
Philips pangaro vous constaterez que je
n'ai pas dit répétition générale j'ai
simplement dit que c'était de bonne
augure pour les Jeux Olympiques est-ce
que vous avez le sentiment que le pays
est déjà derrière son équipe on parlait
de l'effet 98 ce qui s'était passé avec
l'équipe de France de football parce
qu'on a eu plusieurs débats sur
justement à quel point le sport et les
résultats d'une équipe nationale en
Coupe du monde pouvait impacter
l'état d'esprit d'une nation et on
comparé par exemple avec la victoire des
Bleus au foot en 2018 mais je crois que
le fait que ça se joue à domicile amène
vraiment quelque chose de très différent
et donc c'est comparable pour moi qu'à
98 ce qu'on est en train de vivre
j'espère en tous les cas tous les
voyants sont ouverts parce que je crois
qu'on a une magnifique équipe de France
en terme de valeur
on sent des comportements
collectifs individuels la communication
de Fabien Galtier pour l'instant et son
staff est quand même plutôt extrêmement
bien maîtrisé ça ça déborde pas du tout
d'un point de vue
du cadre d'un point de vue des
comportements et puis et puis on voit
une équipe de France dont on est fier
donc voilà ce cette cérémonie
d'ouverture a lancé à lancer les bleus
et je crois que voilà on est parti pour
pour vivre une grande édition voilà
malheureusement le tirage fait que pour
moi on aura très certainement une finale
en quart de finale mais pour être
champion de tout le monde est-ce que
c'est une opportunité pour le rugby de
se propager un petit peu par tout en
France je pense notamment au match de
l'équipe de France qui a eu lieu contre
l'Uruguay à Lille
oui enfin le c'est sûr que c'est pas
tout à fait une terre de rugby même s'il
y a des clubs du Top 14 ils vont
régulièrement c'est toujours des de
vraies fêtes populaires ça fait
longtemps que le 15 de France joue quand
même ailleurs que à Paris dans le
Sud-Ouest ils ont joué un match mythique
contre les All Blacks à Nantes je me
souviens il y a eu il y a des matchs à
Saint-Etienne il y a des matchs enfin je
pense que la carte elle continue quand
même à se la carte du rugby elle quand
même elle continue quand même à
s'étendre après il y a eu un gros effort
en particulier vers les banlieues et
maintenant on a on a des joueurs qui
viennent des banlieues pas seulement
banlieue parisienne par exemple avec
Cameron ou Rocky qui est qui est né à
Saint-Denis qui a commencé le rugby à
Bobigny qui ensuite a joué à Massy donc
ça c'est relativement nouveau par
rapport à la génération de votre oncle
ou effectivement c'était plus sud-ouest
et donc ça évolue un peu même on dit
qu'en terme d'exposition médiatique
c'est le sport numéro 2 en France en
revanche au niveau licencié je crois
donc il y a encore il y a encore un peu
du travail à faire là c'est l'enjeu
majeur le vrai sujet c'est on revient
aux infrastructures à la capacité
d'accueillir dans de bonnes conditions
ses enfants parce que au rugby le vrai
problème c'est la difficulté à les
garder sur la durée là la durée moyenne
de d'une licence d'un enfant c'est deux
ans et demi parce qu'on se rend compte
que c'est difficile de pratiquer proche
de chez soi et c'est un vrai frein à la
pratique et donc il y a beaucoup
d'enjeux avec cette coupe du monde on
attend entre 20 et 30 % licencié en plus
il faut rattraper ce retard entre le
déséquilibre médiatique et le nombre de
licenciés Florian on parle souvent des
valeurs de l'Ovalie aujourd'hui on voit
un peu sourire parce que je trouve que
surtout les opposés au football je
trouve que le football n'est pas aussi
pervers qu'on peut le lire et le rugby
n'est pas non plus aussi angélique on
peut parfois le penser mais oui c'est
valeurs là en tout cas si ces valeurs de
voilà de convivialité de fait etc oui en
tout cas cette équipe de France elle
plaît aussi parce qu'elle elle transpire
ça on transpire c'est une bande de
copains je crois il y a des personnages
il y a des personnalités il y a des
stars ça compte aussi il faut quand même
aussi des antennes Dupont et on sent que
ouais il y a ce côté un peu de l'équipe
de France 98 on sent que c'est pas c'est
pas que des gars qui viennent du
Sud-Ouest et cetera à l'ancienne France
98 on connaissait le nom de
80% des joueurs de l'équipe de France
avant la Coupe du Monde honnêtement le
football avant 98 c'était quand même
plus pour les amateurs de football et
pas pour le grand public j'ai quand même
le sentiment que dans cette équipe de
France de rugby on connaît certains noms
je pense notamment Antoine Dupont bien
sûr tout le monde va le connaître il y a
un déficit de de connaissances des
joueurs vous parlez Marie Barsac de
cette nécessité que de faire connaître
les athlètes olympiques c'est la même
chose en fait alors je j'ai l'impression
que Philippe va me regarder de travers
mais j'ai l'impression que c'est la même
chose pour les joueurs de du 15 de
France on connaît pas tous les noms oui
c'est vrai alors pour autant la
Fédération française de rugby a un
programme dans les écoles pour donner
aussi
aux enfants de rejoindre les clubs de
rugby les filles et les garçons les
filles et les garçons c'est important de
les préciser et évidemment leur donner
envie de regarder les matchs de rugby
après moi je trouve quand même que les
résultats de l'équipe de France de rugby
ces dernières années ils ont gagné on en
a parlé ça a permis quand même de faire
connaître les joueurs donc je dirais que
sont pas si
il y a plus de noms à souvenirs
[Rires]
on a beaucoup moins l'occasion de parler
d'eux dans les grands médias nationaux
c'est vrai qu'on mais par exemple nous
là on commence déjà un peu à faire les
comptes et si on prend je crois nos cinq
plus grands à l'équipe nous à l'équipe
si on prend nos cinq plus grosses ventes
de depuis le début de l'année 2023 on a
trois une rugby quand même donc ça veut
dire que l'équipe de France il y a quand
même une énorme différence entre
l'équipe de France et le Top 14 en
termes en termes d'intérêt en tout cas
de nos lecteurs et du nouveau lecteur on
a la fois des spécialistes et le grand
public et là on voit bien que le grand
public il est vraiment présent pour pour
la Coupe du monde de rugby et pour
l'équipe de France de rugby
président de la République avec tous les
joueurs est-ce que le rugby à la
capacité de ressouder notre nation
pendant un mois oui
moi qui était pleine d'espoir
au bout on parle 98 98 c'est aussi parce
qu'il y a cette victoire qui
déverrouille débloque quelque chose au
niveau sportif et dans la société là il
est évident que on est tous remplis
d'espoir parce qu'on a une équipe
magnifique si ça va au bout c'est sûr
que ça changera des choses si ça va pas
au bout bah malheureusement c'est c'est
le sport il en restera une trace un peu
moins profonde c'est une équipe de
France qui est représentative de
d'absolument toute la société vous
parliez de joueurs issus de
issus des banlieues il y a évidemment
les joueurs du Sud-Ouest mais c'est une
elle ressemble à France 98
pénétration dans les qpv on sent qu'il y
a une adhésion au rugby des jeunes dans
les qpv garçon et fille ça c'est très
positif moi j'étais marqué je sais pas
si vous avez eu pour la campagne
d'Adidas pour promouvoir la Coupe du
monde avec ses athlètes voilà là on sent
qu'on a changé de dimension la
communication foot on va chercher une
autre audience clairement et ce qui me
plaît c'est que je trouve que ce rugby
traditionnel rural
dont Antoine Dupont aldrides sont
l'image
cohabitent hyper bien avec les woki les
gars qui et ça je trouve que c'est de
bonne augure pour la suite bon on a vu
dans ce sens j'étais la Fan Zone de
Saint-Denis ce week-end c'était blindé
il y avait un public fou et pas que
public avec exactement est-ce que cette
fan zone elle vous a fait penser pardon
fille à une répétition générale avant ce
que vous avez envie de voir pour les
Jeux Olympiques alors on l'envisage pas
du tout comme ça nous véritablement on
est d'abord on est sportifs fervent
sportifs et supporters donc nous on est
derrière les Bleus à fond et derrière la
compétition pour qu'elle soit la
meilleure possible après évidemment
qu'on aura des discussions
évidemment comme on a pu le faire cet
été avec nos festivens ces événements là
sont toujours une occasion de de tirer
des enseignements mais
on porte aucun jugement et on est
surtout derrière les Bleus derrière le
le comité d'organisation pour que ça se
passe bien on a déjà collaboré ensemble
voilà pour nous c'est quand même une
super émulation parce que vous allez
garder l'homme coq de la cérémonie
qui va allumer la flamme ou pas
la cérémonie d'ouverture des Jeux
Olympiques bon il y a quand même
[Rires]
on nous intéresser proprement parler aux
Jeux Olympiques je pense à cette
révélation du journal de Times qui
explique qui a un test qui est fait par
l'armée française en ce moment un test
d'un bouclier antidrone afin de
justement pardon Philippe de s'entraîner
pour de voir ce qui va être possible de
mettre en place notamment en termes de
sécurité pour les Jeux Olympiques c'est
quand même des enseignements qui vont
être précieux parce que là on reçoit le
monde entier on a vu qu'il y a eu un
quoi que lors du match lors du match à
Marseille entre l'Angleterre et deux
matchs
anglais après ça a été corrigé le match
suivant aux États Vélodrome on a ouvert
le stade du Nord avant c'était Afrique
du sud-ecosse on peut pas me dire non
plus que les Écossais arrivent très tôt
au stade donc c'est vraiment cette
capacité à s'améliorer c'est évident que
vous vous pouvez en tirer des
enseignements et que ça va être
enrichissant pour oui bien sûr en plus
les hommes qui travaillent aujourd'hui
du côté de l'État sur la Coupe du monde
de rugby seront les mêmes qui vont
travailler sur les Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques dans les préfectures ça
sera les mêmes forcément qu'ils vont
capitaliser sur la Coupe du monde de
rugby c'est évident alors à 10 mois de
la cérémonie d'ouverture de Paris 2024
l'attente de la population est-elle à la
hauteur comme ce qu'on voit en ce moment
avec le avec le rugby les événements
tests de l'été on t-il permis de
corriger d'éventuelles défaillances
c'est la prolongation de sport etc
[Musique]
Marie Barsac je disais vous êtes en
charge de l'impact et de l'héritage au
sein du comité d'organisation des Jeux
de Paris 2024 ça veut dire quoi en fait
on veut
la carte de vide
en fait ce qu'on veut dire c'est qu'on
veut que nos jeux soient utiles et donc
du coup qu'ils aient un impact qui
génère un impact notamment social
sociétal et puis qui laisse une trace
donc l'héritage et cette race elle se
commence très tôt dans le projet parce
que tout ce qui n'aura pas été enclenché
intégré en fait dans la vie quotidienne
ne survivra pas au lendemain des jeux
donc on a travaillé vraiment sur ce côté
des jeux utiles alors déjà utiles parce
que tout ce qu'on peut construire et on
construit peu vous savez on a un concept
des jeux qui s'appuie vraiment sur nos
infrastructures existantes qui sont de
grandes qualités Roland-Garros ce stade
de France c'est pas mal on a quand même
déjà de belles infrastructures et pour
vous avez la ville de Paris pour la
cérémonie d'ouverture
et du coup on utilise l'écran
architectural
mais aussi le château de Versailles pour
l'équitation comme site temporaire pour
accueillir ses épreuves tout ce qu'on
peut construire c'est pour la
Seine-Saint-Denis nous on disait Paris
au service de la Seine-Saint-Denis et
les jeux au service héparis au service
des jeux c'était ça notre slogan en
candidature donc la construction elle
est liée vraiment à des nécessités d'un
territoire donc une piscine donc à
Sandra aquatique parce qu'on manque de
piscine en Seine-Saint-Denis et on
s'arrête pas au centre aquatique on va
aussi laisser en héritage les bassins de
la u Arena qui vont accueillir les
compétitions de natation vont être
implantées demain en 2000 ils sont on
les démontables dans les élèves et on
les met du coup dans des municipalités
de Seine-Saint-Denis pour augmenter le
nombre de bassins pour ce qui est du
village olympique et du village média là
ce sont deux quartiers deux écoquartiers
qui répondent à un besoin d'habitation
de logement dans ces territoires il y
avait déjà évidemment un plan prévu de
logements prévus
avec les moyens de l'État qui sont
évidemment renforcés et puis surtout
toutes les solutions
notamment en termes d'accessibilité et
de développement durable pour montrer
qu'on peut construire mieux d'ici 2030
l'île de demain alors en 2030 est-ce
qu'on pourra se baigner dans la scène
oui c'est sûr non mais c'est vrai le
petit foie
d'abord il faut quand même dire que
c'était des tests events on oublie mais
le mot test voilà c'est important
Thierry qui a fait du théâtre vous le
connaissez il me dit mais quand on fait
une répétition il y a des quoi en fait
mais le jour J c'est impeccable et là
c'est un peu ça on a fait cet estivale
pour voir qu'est-ce qui n'allait pas et
donc évidemment la propreté de la scène
la deadline c'est 2024 donc un an avant
il y a encore des quads donc il y a
cette fameuse vannes évidemment qui a
fait qu'on n'a pas pu organiser les
compétitions de triathlon et para
triathlon mais c'est un bon enseignement
parce que c'est est-ce qu'il y a des
choses qui vont être peut-être
construites pour pouvoir corriger pour
être sûr alors construit non mais
rectifier oui d'accord et puis les
travaux sur la biniabilité les filtres
qui sont mis en place évidemment en
amont de Paris vont continuer à
travailler le travail continue en fait
jusqu'au jeu pour que ce soit propre et
qu'on puisse se baigner dans la scène
effectivement au lendemain des jeux vous
irez vous baigner Jean-Philippe Leclerc
dans la salle
hyper confiant
oui à condition que toutes les vannes
soient bien refermées parce que un petit
un petit souci que personne n'a vu
arriver mais après c'est des jeux qui
sont très importants pour la France pour
Paris ils sont aussi très importants
pour le CIO parce que en fait le
problème du CIO c'est qu'ils avaient de
plus en plus de mal à avoir des villes
candidates parce qu'en gros les jeux
coûtaient cher et puis derrière vous
aviez ce qu'on appelle les éléphants
blancs c'est-à-dire des des structures
sportives qui avaient été construites
pour les jeux et qui servaient plus à
rien donc ça a été une vraie donc là il
y a un nouveau plan de nouvelle vision
tout à l'heure on parlait de la vision
2030 de l'Arabie Saoudite mais il y a
aussi une vision CIO de dire voilà on
doit avoir des des jeux quand même un
peu plus responsables d'où cette notion
d'héritage qui revient maintenant dans
tous les discours CIO Kojo etc mais mais
le CIO après les les Jeux de Tokyo donc
qui ont été complètement bouleversés par
le covid après les Jeux de Rio qui d'un
point de vue populaire ont pas été quand
même une très très grande aussi donc là
le CIO oui il peut pas se rater non plus
sur les sur les jeux de Paris je suis un
petit peu suspecte parce que j'aime
évidemment beaucoup le sport mais il y a
une espèce de bashing autour des Jeux
Olympiques est-ce que c'est pas au bout
d'un moment est-ce que c'est pas
douloureux c'est peut-être accessible
mais vous vous étiez préparé à ce oui
parce qu'on est français et on connaît
les Français
tous les jours donc on connaît le
caractère des Français a toujours voir
le vert à moitié vide plutôt qu'à moitié
plein après nous on attend d'être jugé
finalement sur sur les actes et sur les
résultats quelque part c'est ne nous
jugez pas avant attendez par exactement
maintenant on a déjà des choses à dire
vous montriez tout à l'heure le
président de la République qui parlait
de cette 30 minutes d'activité physique
quotidienne ça c'est une initiative de
Paris 2024 qui a été proposée à
l'éducation nationale qui a été
expérimentée et qui maintenant concerne
toutes les écoles de France donc c'est
un héritage on travaille beaucoup sur
l'héritage des Jeux paralympiques là
aussi on essaie de faire vraiment bouger
les lignes changer le regard sur le
handicap un autre exemple on a lancé euh
avec le Comité paralympique et la mairie
de Paris une initiative en 2020 de club
inclusif c'est des formations qui sont à
destination de club omnisport c'était
les grands clubs omnisports parisiens le
public par exemple je regarde le rugby
qui ont formé leur éducateurs à
accueillir des personnes aussi sur du
handicap et former les membres du club à
être anti-accueillant oui donc c'est pas
toujours impacts
héritage de Paris
les clubs nous ont dit effectivement ça
marche les personnes se sont du handicap
dans l'étude d'un pas qu'on a amené on
dit oui je reviens je suis assidue je
suis fidélisée et donc du coup l'état
dit bah ok j'accompagne le financement
pour qu'il y ait 30000 3000 clubs en
2024 donc il y a déjà il y a déjà un
impact de Paris 2024 donc je ne sais pas
si on pourra empêcher le bashing je
crois pas il y a une chose que Carl leaf
député renaissance des Yvelines
souhaiterait empêcher et interdire
pendant la durée des Jeux c'est la grève
Florian Gazan vous êtes les grèves c'est
un droit comme on peut l'interdire comme
ça je sais pas je veux bien mais enfin
je l'espère
au travail avec les syndicats vous le
savez oui absolument donc ça c'est on a
signé une charte sociale après la grève
c'est un droit constitutionnel donc il
n'est pas écrit dans la Charte sociale
qu'ils ont interdictions
la veille d'un événement d'ouverture des
jeux ou d'une coupe du monde de rugby et
quand même très différent après on a un
dialogue vraiment construit avec eux
réguliers on a un comité de la suivi de
la Charte sociale qui se réunit tous les
mois les encore vu lundi dernier donc on
entretient le dialogue et la réalité
quand même c'est que l'effet de les
avoir on a vu certains syndicats qui se
sont engagés effectivement oui en fait
on dialogue avec eux ils nous challenge
on apporte des solutions ils font partie
véritablement de du projet ils sont au
conseil d'administration donc du coup il
y a une co-construction quand même du
projet qui savait est-ce que je suis un
tout petit peu trop romantique ou est-ce
que je sais c'est une utopie est-ce
qu'on peut imaginer pendant les Jeux
Olympiques une concorde nationale c'est
la trêve et on est tous heureux pardon
c'est un peu
oui on peut l'espérer ça va dépendre
beaucoup comme des résultats le sport
est un peu l'opium du peuple en ce
moment-là c'est-à-dire que si
effectivement on a une très belle
compétition que les Français gagnent
dans tous les sens on va oublier nos
petits nos petits soucis nos petits
problèmes après si c'est moi le cas et
ben ça les quoi que seront plus visibles
et donc voilà on râlera parce que ça
roule mal dans Paris parce que on trouve
pas de taxi
voilà on sera c'est les deux côtés de la
France on verra voilà c'est il y a deux
balances on verra le quel plateau va
l'emporter quoi alors il y a une
question quand même qui se qui se pose
encore qui devait être résolu cet été
c'est la question de la présence ou pas
des athlètes russes et biélorusses à ces
Jeux Olympiques est-ce que les Jeux
olympiques de Paris seront un échec si
les Ukrainiens ne viennent pas à Paris
parce que les Ukrainiens menacent de
boycotter les jeux si les athlètes
russes ce serait terrible pour les gens
serait terrible pour Paris ce serait
terrible pour la France patrie des
Droits de l'Homme si on avait des des
athlètes russes ou pavillon neutre et
pas d'ukrainien ce serait un désastre
pour moi ce sera un désastre alors le
président de la République s'est exprimé
dans les colonnes de L'Équipe d'ailleurs
c'est vous Jean-Philippe qui l'avait
qu'il avait interviewé il a donné une
position qui est la sienne un souhait
d'accueillir les ukrainiens et
éventuellement les Russes mais sans leur
drapeau et c'est horrible donc des
Russes ce qui est plus ou moins la la la
position
le président de la République
évidemment il ne peut pas y avoir le
drapeau russe au jeu de Paris je crois
que ça fait consensus parce que la
Russie comme pays n'a pas sa place à un
moment où elle a commis des crimes de
guerre où elle déporte des enfants
mais la situation n'appartient pas au
président de la République est-ce que
vous pouvez nous expliquer Marie Barsac
comment elle va à qui elle appartient
cette décision alors la décision
n'appartient au CIO et aux fédération
internationales donc nous pareil comme
c'est l'organisation ne prononçons pas
sur sur ce sujet
vous imaginez bien que le sujet est pris
au plus haut niveau et traité au jour le
jour en fonction de rappeler
olympique donc on a vu des fédérations
avoir des positions différentes on a vu
la Fédération des scribes peut-être que
vous c'était en parler ou commenter qui
a eu voilà à gérer une situation pas
simple entre deux athlètes qui ne
voulaient pas attendu en tout cas ne
voulait pas serrer la main à l'autre
donc on voit que les choses sont
mouvantes et que c'est pas si facile on
peut décréter des principes et après la
réalité de la compétition et des
athlètes même et de leur ressentir et de
leur vécu c'est encore autre chose donc
ce sujet est vraiment très très
important
des Jeux Olympiques réussit pour vos
maris Barsac ça serait des Jeux
Olympiques comment avec une fête
populaire
on l'a dit tout à l'heure donc oui des
médailles une fête populaire un
engouement populaire une fierté
nationale que tout le monde soit fier
d'accueillir le monde parce que c'est
quand même ça les jeux c'est accueillir
le monde entier à la fois pour les Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques
on va se quitter sur ces mots on se
souhaitant à tous de très beaux jeux
olympiques nous aurons évidemment
l'occasion de d'y revenir pourquoi ça
vous fait rire Florent gazon d'être très
bonsoir
On va rester sur la Coupe du monde de
rugby on va penser très fort au bleu on
va souhaiter faire tous la fête le 28
octobre lors de lors de la finale en
espérant une victoire évidemment du 15
de France Merci à tous les quatre merci
à vous de nous avoir suivis un immense
merci à toutes les équipes techniques et
les équipes éditoriales qui m'ont aidé à
préparer cette émission nous nous
retrouvons dans 15 jours pour un nouveau
numéro de sport etc à bientôt
Public Sénat en partenariat avec
l'équipe vous a présenté sport etc
[Musique]